hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game it's from round three of
yesterday's paris rapid and blitz a game
between temura java and alireza ferrugia
and it features again
a very nice idea involving the e5 square
as you might have imagined
uh or rather i don't know why you would
imagine that since i still haven't
mentioned it but we will get
we will get to that so uh rajab with the
white pieces opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 c4 e6 knight to
f3 and
d5 now so again nothing out of the
ordinary just the queen's gambit decline
on the board
uh knight to c3 and now c6 uh going for
the semi-slav defense with bishop to g5
and h6 now asking do you want to go back
or do you want to trade on f6 here at a
job of captures we have
queen captures on f6 and now e3 so just
nicely continuing development knight to
d7
and now rook to c1 we have g6
and now bishop to d3 and the position
has been reached before known museum d
captures in c4 bishop to g7 but here
alireza plays a new move he plays queen
to e7 so already as of move 9 we have a
completely new game
and the queen is a bit better suited on
e7 since after bishop g7 you want your
bishop on this diagonal not to the queen
blocking the bishop
so here uh we have just castles by the
job of ending now
bishop to g7 we have queen to c2
in the now black castles with rook after
d1 completing development
uh and now d captures on c for bishop
captures and c5 and here
uh black was able to execute c5 he's
saying okay if i if i'm able to
play c captures on d4 then surely white
cannot claim any opening advantage
uh sort of decides the uh to push the
pawn he plays d5
and now while you could capture the
spawn uh after pawn captures knight
captures it's a really
really bad position for black uh you
don't really have
all that all that much to do with the
queen you can go back then knight to f4
and
it's a really really ugly ugly position
for black so instead after d5 we have
knight to b6
and now with more pressure on the d5
pawn and the now
b3 simply defending the bishop here we
have knight captures b
captures and b6 now now the light square
bishop can also enter the game
uh we have e4 that job of strengthens
the center here
and now e captures on d5 and now here's
a
another very nice moment you could
capture with the c pawn and create a
pass pawn you could capture with the e
pawn and create a pass pawn
uh but uh tamer grabs with the knight
uh the problem is if you go see captures
then uh
while well this is playable maybe it's
uh well
maybe it's a bit easy for black to
continue development let's say bishop to
g4 and then you simply get
the the rooks into the game uh or if you
play e
captures on d5 instead then you even
allow bishop to f5 which is a
perfect developing square for for the
dark square bishop uh
so instead after he captures on the five
knight characters and e5 with an attack
on the queen on e7
queen to b7 ended now h3 preventing
bishop to g4 so now you can't go here
you can't go here
so you will go here so bishop to e6 by
uh ferugia
and now rook to d2 now we're gonna
double up rooks on the d
file we have rook f the e8 preparing to
bring the other rook over to d8
rook c to d1 and now rook 8 d8 and
black also uh completed his development
we have queen to a for now
uh with ideas that maybe if this knight
moves you will not be able to capture
here because then the rook
will be hanging so it's it's a very
active position for the white queen
so bishop to d7 if you kick the queen
back queen back to c2
and now bishop to c6 now the bishop will
be
a little bit uh more active on this
diagonal perhaps
if this knight ever decides to move
because now if this is ever captured
then you will get a very very strong
pass pawn
so here knight to h2 time to get the
other knight into the game as well
king the h8 and now knight to g4
we have h5 trying to bait this but this
would actually be a pretty big mistake
uh if rajabo goes for this uh then he
attacks the rook rookie 6 and
the knight is lost the the knight has no
squares where
it can retreat to as the the h5 pawn uh
covers the g4 square so instead after h5
we have knight back to h2
now the knight will have to find its way
back into the game via the f3 square
and now rook to d7 now we can also
double up on the d
file uh we have knights to f3 and now
queen to a6 a very tricky move by
ferugia
if rajabo is not careful and plays
something weird let's say like king h2
then bishop to a4 just
wins the exchange so you have to be be
careful so here we have rook the b1
uh sidestepping this threat we have
queen to a4
uh if um queen to a4 and now rook to b3
and now after rook to b3 if you try to
repeat this for example with queen to a6
and then maybe you tried to
win material this way then you can just
play rook uh
uh rook b to d3 and now uh yoruk came
from d1 to d3 which is super impressive
uh and you don't have to worry about any
bishop to a four idea so of course
first abandons this idea altogether he
plays bishop to b7
uh and now comes a move that i thought
was really really incredible and
basically why i
uh why i decided to show this game here
at a job of played e5
and uh rajab has been great at spotting
this
e5 square ideas for a very long time he
basically owns the e5 square ever
ever since march 5th 2009 if you know
what i mean
and it's just a just a very uh
incredible move
uh now alireza has to deal with this
somehow
but how do you do this the problem is if
the pawn is captured let's say knight
captures rook captures
then we get queen to b2 and you lose the
game there's no way to defend here
uh your only move is f6 then we're just
gonna eliminate
this and again uh you can't move the
knight because then there are
uh you can't move the rook because then
we have some very nasty discoveries
and if you double up here then we can
just play rook to e3
and again there is no playing this if
you move this then you allow this
uh king to be exposed so we're just
going to play rook to d8 to check
king to g7 now a nice double check from
the queen and the knight
and after something like this we're
going to deliver czech king g5 and let's
say queen to f6
with checkmate so these are the ideas
that could become a reality if alireza
is not careful
so after e5 capturing an e5 is not
possible uh however
it is and this is uh where alireza
missed it
uh he has to capture an e5 but not right
away he first eliminates the knight
as as you've seen in this line uh after
bishop captures an e5 if uh
you know you you missed it for some
reason after queen b2 we have to play f6
but f6 is impossible because of the
knight here
so then we go back and we say okay so
what if the knight wasn't there we
captured the knight and then the idea
works we just capture here
and then after knight captures rook
captures queen b2 we can play f6 and
we're we're doing fine there's nothing
nothing to worry about here it's still a
very tricky position but black is up
upon and black is better
and even if uh even if you don't like
this position it's definitely the best
you can get from from that um position
where a java pushed e5 but
alireza played a different idea uh here
alireza played
bishop to a6 now putting pressure on the
on this
c for pawn but this is not enough and
here
rajabo goes for it knight to f6 now with
uh with an attack on both rooks so you
have to capture on d2
so rook captures on the two queen
captures and then now comes
rook to f8 you have to keep an eye
on the rook the knight controls now g8
and e8 uh
and now comes a move that well it's not
easy to spot
there are a couple of good moves here
but one is simply devastating
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this incredible idea or a
job of played
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding other
knight the h4
or queen to g5 those are all great moves
but the move that absolutely destroys
black is a rook to d3 so congratulations
to everyone who found this rajabo found
it and now there really isn't
anything black can do rook is coming to
d8 and it's it's incredible
but there is nothing alireza can do here
to give you an example if you try and
eliminate one of the attackers
just queen h6 check king here uh e
captures an f6 and you're getting
checkmated
so we are definitely not uh we're not
touching uh
this knight on f6 it it has to remain
there and uh
you don't really have all that many
other moves for example if queen
captures on c4 we just go rook to d8
and what do you play now uh if you
capture just queen captures here so you
could bring the queen back to help out
with the defense
but then knight the g5 now attacks the
queen and after queen e7 there's the
incredible queen to d6 and black resigns
this is
it's been a while since i've seen a
position this incredible this is just uh
this is just so so great uh
there's nothing you can do here the
problem is if queen captures
then knight captures an f7 with
checkmate this is
simply disgusting and i'm even gonna use
this for
for the thumbnail this is this is so
incredible that uh
it's uh uh it's it's it never happened
in the game but
like we always say the most beautiful
parts of our chess game never actually
happen
on the board and even if you try
removing again one of the defenders
now we just play rook captures on f8 and
now again there's nothing to be done
here
once the king goes here we're just going
to play rook captures on f7 and this is
how we again
win the queen queen captures knight
captures and there's no no playing this
uh so really uh incredible stuff so
after this rook the d3 already
played bishop captures in c4 now the
queen will be able to
go back via the c6 square but it's still
not enough
rook to d8 and here it's just completely
lost for
for alireza queen to c6 was played we
have rook capture sunday fate would
check bishop
captures and now queen to d8 threatening
the bishop
so king to g7 defending the only square
uh
and now comes knight to d7 and now both
the queen
and the knight are attacking the f8 and
the f6 square
and there's uh not that arrow and
there's nothing for black to do here you
can't move the bishop because
well there's just nowhere for for it to
go so bishop to d6 was played you don't
have anything better and now
queen to f6 with check came to g8 and
now the simplest way
uh queen captures and the e6 just wins
the piece and that's it all it is a
traded queens here
uh and grabbed this pawn now you do have
three connected pass pawns here so maybe
you can still fight
but rajabov plays uh it incredibly
accurately he plays knight captures on
b6 and now of course if the pawn is
captured we just promote
this pawn so all it is akin to do this
he has to go
uh be active with the king but now we
just deliver check and pick up the other
pawn as well
so from three connected past pawns we we
reach a position where there are
almost no past pawns so king the e8
knight captures here to make matters
worse
your king does not have a square here
your pawn and knight
cover everything uh we have a5 and now
knight to d4 the other knight now joins
the action
uh bishop to d5 we have f3 g5 and now
king to f2 so black without
without a single idea king to d8 and now
king to e3 we have h4 king to d3
and he was in this position on move uh
48 that alireza firuja resigned the game
and this incredible victory was achieved
by tamora jabo
after again utilizing the e5 square
so incredible stuff and uh it's even
more incredible that alireza did not uh
take take on e5 after e5 just
just takes and then takes but even
alireza can miscalculate uh
it would seem and this is all uh tamer
needed to
grab that little edge and then you know
just uh claw his way to
to this incredible victory uh but yeah
even all those lines that never actually
happened on the board were super
impressive so i thought you might enjoy
them as well
so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it after three rounds of the
rapid the leaders are nepo arunian
wesley so and
peter svidler so we're gonna see what
happens after day two there's gonna be
three days of rapid and two days of
blitz like i said
and do join us today we're gonna have a
nice celebratory uh birthday arena
today at 8 pm central european time the
link is in the description below
uh under the price fund has been
increased somewhat as some of you guys
decided to to contribute to to increase
the price fund so i think for that uh
it's gonna be
uh even more legendary uh so yeah once
again hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank ben blackburn
uh and michael castano for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend